hello welcome back to big mood we missed
you hope you're having a fantastic
quarantine so yo I have been loving
quarantine so eat nuts we've all been
very weak we've all just your normal
life oh my god how we're gonna do this
we're all talking over each other we're
new to this yeah yeah this is a little
different than our typical episodes
we're all recording from home remotely
so excuse us if we talk over each other
we're just not used to not seeing each
other in person while we're recording
these having like the in-person energy
because then you can sense like when
someone's trying to talk or whatever's
but like online like video like this
it's it's difficult it's hard how am I
supposed to play with Tiff's hair you
can't it's in a bun yeah if you need to
cut a piece of your hair a lock of her
hair send it to Jeana just stroke it
lightly stroking episode this is so cool
everyone kind of gets like a peeking out
into our our bedrooms right now our
house I'm in my living room
yes my TV my fake plant in my kit you
gonna buzz my kid yeah you guys are
straight-up in my house right now
so yeah but you gotta be buzzed I like
it oh thank you
it's from impressions pure vanity I can
say that because they have supported me
Nikki and Jeana and it's actually super
dope yeah three love it it makes me they
make good good I just be taking videos
now all the time and I use it as almost
like a ring light it's amazing
the straight-up remote next paid for
that flip and an invoice so actually
what we were gonna talk about for
today's episode was just like how
everybody's adjusting to this quarantine
because for some of us at me and Gina we
freaking love it and the the rest of us
might be going a little stir-crazy so
take it away house
how's your guys's core genes do you
wanna direct people to talk because
let's go let's start with tip I'll just
go down the line
oh yeah okay quarantines been great I
have been getting a ton of stuff done in
the new house as you can see the bedroom
is like kind of set up I did stage some
stuff but it's really getting there it
is so good thank you
so cement awesome like it actually
happened like this whole quarantine
stuff happened like perfect timing kind
of because then now we have all this
time to spend to get the house ready and
then Isaac's not going to school anymore
like in person now he's doing online
school and so it's just a lot of family
time and a lot of Minecraft playing a
lot of my bridging a lot of the office
Isaac is like so obsessed with the
office when he's already binge the
entire show one thing he's watching it
for the second time
have you guys played Animal Crossing it
no not yet you know like minecraft
okay you should I gotta ask him if he's
down because if he's not down then it's
pointless yeah there's an unlimited like
list of things you can do except I
bought a switch like three weeks ago for
it nope actually a month ago for Animal
Crossing I played it for two days and
then I just stopped it's fun but I just
have really bad ADHD and it's like a
very relaxing game like you're supposed
to just wrap up in a blanket and play
and I thought that I could do that but
like my brain doesn't turn off so it's
hard for me too it's so hard and now I'm
so behind all of my friends I just
stopped playing there's so many tasks
though yeah like it takes care of that
task list for me in my brain you're
perfect for that game yeah yeah it's so
is like you get my chores pay my bills
then go but do my DIYs then decorate my
house it's a life but in a video game is
crossing basically
on an island if I could yeah so funny Oh
actually I built my house on an island
in Minecraft so not that far off oh
there you go so I usually tuck in your
sheets do you see this [ __ ] I just I
just slept that [ __ ] on and just oh my
god this is as far as it goes I try at
least see how is she on your bed when we
were doing equipment testing there was
nothing it looked like a Bachelor is a
bit of a dreary looking set yeah going
on laundry day I'll do it you want to
see you want to see the [ __ ] killer
here oh my gosh I know she was just
gonna spread him
is she gonna yeah I was like what she
gonna show us her massive buy Raider
what is a nice personality you're only
listening to the audio of this and
you're not on video you got to come to
the YouTube video and watch my blanket
with some sort of lies white dragon
blue-eyes white dragon guys that's what
I used to call who's that hot politician
named Ryan with blue eyes I forgot Oh
Paul Ryan yeah like it when I was in
fourth grade I had a crush on Paul Ryan
and I used to call him blue-eyes white
dragon and then I found out that he was
like kind of bad so what do you have my
political crush
I just think of the muscle picture that
he took that everyone makes fun of oh my
god I need to look that up right now yes
you do have ADHD it's like Paul Ryan
need to look it up I wish we could like
put our own like stuff on the screen
like if we were able to like look up
things and then like share stuff on the
screen immediately that would be fun you
could yeah and you can choose I don't
know we'll figure it out you know
show-and-tell for a podcast yeah off
screen record screen jail this is cool I
mean like this is basically my dream
come chill hang out my friends but I
don't to leave my house hey like I I
never thought that this would be a dream
of mine but now it has been like
honestly quarantine for me has made me
more of a homebody like even when I'm
home buddy or I used to be extremely
extremely extroverted and I would hate
being at home but ever since be like I
think the
is my 18th day 17th day in a row that
having left my house and I've been
loving it some way I may become Agora
for but growth for before a phono phobic
okay feeling that I've been feeling that
a little bit like I want to go outside
so bad and then I'm like oh I need to go
to the store and then I start panicking
I'm like no I can't cause tor the phobia
is said in it's really weird because I
went nuts of all people like I was going
insane because I think my quarantine
started 18 years ago it's like we're
like I need to get out the house so I
booked a hotel for the weekend just like
isolate you know hotel just be out of my
area for a little bit and I feel a lot
better now that's how what you be scared
at all being in a public hotel no
because um like I literally interacted
with one person the front desk and
that's it and look we were all mashed up
and gloved and then like the hotel
occupancy was only like 15 percent yeah
super low yeah so like no one was around
it was [ __ ] awesome well and then now
that I'm home like Who am I gonna be
directing play games again so I just
reset my my timer I'm another good 18
years according to you know be blanks
and you know the going even going
outside I went outside for to go on a
walk just like get some fresh air and
some Sun but because the weather is
changing seasonally like we're going
into spring and then like it's been
raining and then sunny and then raining
in the sunny my allergies have been
going wild and then I'm like is that is
that the virus virus it's the freaking
yeah my eyes are all itchy and then my
nose is running and I'm like I know the
strategies but then I'll see I like a
headline it's like something about your
eyes or something I'm like oh now I have
it for sure of it
dude I never get allergies but I started
like sneezing like crazy just today and
then I'm like oh my god
I haven't been outside I haven't talked
to anyone how can I get anything right
now like I have my getting sick because
then I think what you're intending to
you're in a new area so maybe like
because you've moved so far away it's
like totally different trees and stuff
out there
you're like adjusting you know I miss a
little morning I lost out of my house
I miss easing all morning almost until
hospital cuz this carry myself
I know I've always been a hypochondriac
and I think getting the virus is like
the least scariest thing that I've
thought that I've had I've gone to the
hospital thinking I had a heart attack
before I thought I had some kind of like
crazy STD before because my entire body
broke out in rashes and none of them
were the thing but they were like things
that were close to like they had the
same symptoms as a heart attack or that
is nasty
so it was like it's always been like
doop doop were you were you a googler
hypochondriac - yes I racked up
thousands in hospital bills and that's
what stopped my hypochondria because of
how bad the hospital boats all right
yeah because like it would be 2 a.m. and
I'd be like I'd be like ok here my
symptoms heart failure ok mom take me to
the emergency always been I pecan your
ex who knew yeah ok it's like accordance
I have a swollen prostate mom failure
even Johnson syndrome where it's like if
you take a medicine that your body
reacts adversely to and your skin starts
falling off and I was like mom I showed
her picture of it I was like this could
happen to me like I was 18 and just had
a horrible anxiety yeah I definitely
haven't you hard thinking I have
something like if I think that I have
something I don't even bother going to
the doctor I'm like well I'm gonna die
oh oh zero survival skills have some
because she's got the agoraphobia now
that's a survival skill so you've got
something something no recently I was
watching this movie I forgot what it was
called but at the end so like the whole
premise of the movie is that there's all
these people they get together and then
they find out that the world is ending
and then they have to like somehow
survive together but at the end of it
they decided that well it's pointless
like we're gonna die in a few hours
anyway so we might as well just kill
ourselves now
and so I went to sleep like like
dreaming about that where I'm like right
now the crota bar like I don't know what
my brain went to this place in my head
where I'm like well might as well just
end it myself I'm not gonna wait no no
and I woke up I was like that was a
dream that was a drink that was great Oh
oh my god I think we need to be careful
this the stuff we're watching right now
I kind of don't like that everyone's
watching contagion and all that stuff
and like making themselves feel worse
about it watch no I'm excited in this
coronavirus quarantine I've decided that
I'm gonna move to Florida and or
Oklahoma do meth and own a bunch of
Tigers okay so use on Tiger key I have
goals and dreams in life now and it's to
move to Florida and do meth and old a
bunch of Tigers so you Lackawanna Oh
last night I well a little bit ago I
found joy exotics youtube channel before
the documentary and had about 60,000
followers and he was trying to do sizzle
reels and pitch for a show so I think
that he originally pitched to Netflix to
do a whole reality show about him cuz he
was already filming when it's in those
yeah that's in the show like he was
trying to get a show done yeah yeah I
think they signed up for that and then
they realized there was this crazy
backstory when you watch his videos dude
my favorite one is this 20 minute video
about him running for president and he's
like calling out Trump and he goes on
this 10 minutes high-rate about why
people should be able to euthanize
themselves and his so he's basically
like if I want to [ __ ] die I should
be able to [ __ ] die going and going
and going anywhere platform to like
there's so much about and he's like and
he's walking in the tiger cage with this
like brace on his leg and this like arm
thing and like every couple of seconds
he looks over at the tiger to make sure
that he's good and like I was like dude
this is intense cuz also Joe looks like
he smells kind of funny and I so I just
can't imagine any around these Tigers
all fit to me
like I feel like he would smell like
like like a stale meth probably yeah
real bad like like something kind of
stale you know you smell bad furniture I
feel like he buys his Cologne in like a
gas station it's quote it's called like
hot swamp or something I almost couldn't
even watch that series like it hurt me
so bad to know that that is my brethren
my southern brethren that is actually
earlier on in the year he texted me and
he was like hey you have to watch this
[ __ ] series and I was like this is
you're gonna text me now and it's gonna
be about a [ __ ] documentary anyway so
then I go to watch the show right I get
like 17 minutes into the first show and
I was or the first [ __ ] yeah episode
and I could not watch it I had second
hell secondhand embarrassment so bad oh
oh not so you this I turned it off and I
waited 24 hours those like I'm gonna
make it through I'm gonna watch this
[ __ ] series everyone's talking about
it I forced myself because it's really
good it got way better but it was hard
for me to watch that I was like oh
Jess Jess you have a type because when I
saw it I was like this is Jojo Sakawa
would want definitely a like a stand out
as far as the people I've dated Joe is
nothing like any of the other people
I've dated so much you know honestly
though cause I've only seen Casey and I
have only seen the first episode and
like you have to get through the first
really you know a few minutes in we were
like this is this is Joe yes Oh Joe's
ever seen like I hated it I can't stand
watch like every single person on that
show is abhorrent I hate all of them
suck yeah absolutely I suck so
hilariously yeah it's like no comedy
could ever write something like that
like if that was a comedy I'd be like
they went too far like they did too much
but that's why were real people I like
that one guy that runs like a cult that
like where he has like a harem how did
who are these women and why are they
like like willing to [ __ ] that guy like
what
there's always souls this is his dick is
enlightenment
like enlightenment is through no no he
said yeah and they believed him clearly
because I think they want to be there
for some reason but I don't know why I
want to be there cuz they don't so pay
for anything yeah I guess man they get
to take pictures with big cats and yoga
retreat I feel also for the cats all be
it like that all of them are [ __ ] up
and I mean okay I'm not gonna lie the
whole like Carroll Baskins getting away
with murder thing kind of [ __ ] dope
yeah kind of goals
yeah but also like I don't like about
her is that she just she she's better
than everyone she's basically the same
exact thing oh yeah you know what I mean
looks like a self-awareness yeah zero
but I mean like if I can get away with
the murder with the cheating husband
that's [ __ ] sick there's another
episode coming out like a follow-up
episode I think I don't know they
decided to built the reunion episode you
know what did did anyone else watch the
platform I did no you guys got to watch
that
honestly I'm it's like I I will say and
I think this is like pretty public that
a lot of people said that the ending was
like a little lackluster but like eight
8/2 hold on what's the letter that comes
before Z a 2 X 8 X it why why why is he
well why was still a little shaky y&z
were a little shaky
it was [ __ ] I was like mmm bro and I
don't watch horror movies and I watched
it at 2 o'clock in the morning no no
dude can you guys please watch it and
let us know what you think
you said the Netflix yeah ending
worldwide like number four or something
she's cool yeah it's okay wait okay so
that's what it's about
Oh cuz also for viewers those Oilers no
spoilers no spoilers it's it's about
it's about like a futuristic thing where
there's a massive vertical prison and it
has like oh okay okay okay yeah
like there's something that comes down
and it goes through each level like
level 1 2 3 Cory yeah a little gory yeah
to me it looked too predictable like the
whole thing was just gonna be like I
could like I could figure out like the
whole time it was just gonna be this
this guy like anxious like they're gonna
start eating each other they like start
falling through and then die and I'm
just like I already get the whole movie
I already get it from just from the guys
all I gotta say is if I was level one no
one's gettin [ __ ] and level 2 oh my god
lobster and [ __ ] I'll piss all over that
[ __ ] it's it's not not as predictable as
I think cuz it's not like I saw the
trailer and I was like okay well I
already watched the whole movie it's
about the feeling it's very immersive I
mean it's very the way that it's shot
it's very very personal and you almost
feel like you're in his shoes which I
think that's why it's so captivating
it's a little bit less about the story
structure like I felt like I was in his
position it was incredibly well shot for
the budget that it was shot on yeah it
looks pretty a little bit but yeah it's
like what two scenes geez oh yeah like
two locations tops yeah and you know
about like sketches and scenes and [ __ ]
like that I'd be so curious to hear what
you thought about it yeah
horror movies are the best if you're
like if that's your first film like it's
the best return on investment because
one they're evergreen people always want
to see horror movies they do they're
always in demand no matter what and then
too you can shoot them on really low
budget and make it look good because you
don't have to invest that much in
locations or costuming or you can get
like really low grade actors like you
don't have to have like an a-list
celebrity for a horror movie to do well
so yeah there's a lot of reasons that
because I feel like there's I mean of
course there's a few movies but if you
weigh out dramas versus horror movies
there's more a listers and dramas and
comedies and there are in horror movies
because yeah that's that's a really cool
thought thank you what have you been up
to during quarantine you said that it's
been very enlightening fun what's going
on / yeah well I mean to be honest I'm
the queen of loneliness so I feel like
then you know I was raised being alone
all the time and I've always found ways
to entertain myself and this has just
been just heaven for me because one my
schedule doesn't change at all like I I
still do exactly the same things I blog
I put I make youtube videos I put them
up like I guess the only things that
have changed are the outside productions
like JK and big mood obviously but a lot
of those were stockpiled so it didn't
feel like I was missing out on very much
I just got a lot of extra time back to
do the things that like I felt like I
didn't have time to do before like read
all my books and learn new editing
things that I really wanted to do and
get better at making thumbnails and like
all the things that I felt rushed
through before I am no longer rushed
through and I also get very drained I
love hanging out with people but I get
very drained whenever I socialize and I
have to like it takes me out for like a
day yeah after going to like a social
event or even like filming with people
so yeah just not having to be around
other people I've kept a lot of that
energy and funneled them into new
projects and new things that like keep
my energy up and I got a treadmill so
I've got you know what Niki great I
heard you did a little bit of shopping
did you happen to buy it oh hell yes
cuz are your titties I only shop for
bras at one place and that is third love
my first bra to try out and I fell in
love and I got hooked just to do like
that Mickey and I smooth as hell I see
and I just knew I just really wanted to
know about my bra dude what I love about
third bra is they have a fit quiz that
you take and so you always get the
perfect fitting bra they have so many
sizes including half sizes for every
booby shape and I didn't even know
before using third LeBrons that my bras
weren't fitting my breasts correctly I
didn't know there wasn't supposed to be
a huge gap in between your breasts
breast disease and the top of the bra
and I would always have my legs
traps falling down it was just a mess
and I just thought like oh that's how
bras are you just wear them and you're a
mess no not the case I ordered a third
lebra for taking their quiz and it fits
like a dream like it is perfect and
there's like very little padding in it
but it still looks like my breasts are
very round like look it like you got
them soft breasts naturally it's
hands-down the most comfortable raw I've
ever owned every bra is made for your
comfort with memory foam cups no slip
straps and smooth scratch free band with
the printed label third lug knows
there's a perfect bra out there for
everyone so right now they're offering
our listeners 15% off your first order
go to third love comm slash big mood
right now to find your perfect fitting
bra and get 15% off your first purchase
that's third love comm slash big mood
for 15% off today we'll do anything and
y'all know during quarantine this is the
best time to pick up a habit but it's
also the best time to break a habit and
how do we do that with noon ladies and
gentlemen okay
noon lets you achieve specific goals by
not just achieving the goals but
changing your mindset in getting you to
that spot forever it's not just a
one-time weight-loss it's not like a
one-time you know wake up in the morning
you actually have a coach that's
reminding you like hey do this it's like
an accountability partner and a way to
shift your psychology all in one app
okay it's based in psychology so new
teaches you why you do the things that
you do and it also empowers you with the
tools to break the bad habits and
replace them with new ones so it's based
on a cognitive behavioral approach and
it uses personalized courses to help you
reach your goals so everyone's busy
except for right now and noon gives you
this time to reach your goals that's
right only 10 minutes a day but you know
what while you're in quarantine give
them 25 let's expedite this let's break
there you go so sign up for your child
today at noon calm /big mood that's
right noon in oom calm /big mood to
start your trial today that's new
such big mood get it you get it yeah
you're a quarantine time um it there's
been a it's it's been really interesting
um I think Jess and I are both in like
kind of similar
I guess predicament where we're both
kind of like home bodies but Jess and I
are the only people that live completely
alone um I you know I have a I have a
lot of space here which is fantastic but
and I am an introvert always have been
an introvert like when this first
happened I was like wow this is like my
ultimate fantasy and just everyone's
living in it with me I mean as far as
like the introversion and the homebody
misko's and it's been really good but
one of the cool things about LA is that
like the weather and the sunshine and
the city and the hustle and bustle kind
of really got me out of my depression
when I moved here and I kind of missed
that I I'm very grateful for you know
the sunshine and the people that are
here and to have that kind of taken away
has made things different I I feel like
I'm 20 years old again um I've been
streaming on Twitch again I've been
going to sleep at 4 o'clock in the
morning I've been like gaming a lot more
so it's weird it feels like I am kind of
where I was five years ago except I'm
not living with my parents I'm allowed
to do whatever I want and get drunk and
all this [ __ ] but I'm gonna be honest
there's kind of like a weird feeling of
emptiness with it um I enjoy coming back
to it but and I've been working a lot
more but it feels like everything that
I'm doing it's a little bit different in
the direction I want to end up in the
next five years so it feels like this
this these a few weeks like I'm a
workaholic it feels like I don't know it
feels like my life is on pause in a
weird way and I don't I think I told you
guys this too but like obviously I
haven't like mentioned it to our viewers
like one of the reasons I quit my job in
February was because I scored some
really cool gigs and unfortunately
Entertainment has shut down so both of
my productions were originally
completely shut down luckily one of them
sparked back up and it's in development
which is great
I'm really excited about that but
everything else has really slowed down
but you know I don't I don't like to
talk about that too much because there's
so many people that are in like you know
a rough position right now yeah I've
been trying to you know order out a lot
like a lot of like post mates and stuff
and like trying to take care of
restaurants and like I'm sipping 25% cuz
I'm like oh my goodness like this is
crazy in the most social interaction I
have is with my post mate like I I have
just you've met them I have neighbors
that live in my building like three
doors down which is amazing they're dope
as hell they like to drink with me we
have board game nights
but unfortunately my boyfriend's parents
are his dad is auto immune compromised
so I if I want to see my boyfriend I
can't see anybody mm-hmm
so that's been kind of rough and you
know we are seeing each other in two
week increments to be safe so I'm
literally completely alone in and I
normally I like this but it's it's been
a little challenging you know when it's
forced upon you and it's like too much
and you know that the whole world is
grinding to this like scary halt and the
economy's like [ __ ] free-falling it's
like wait this is not exactly the dream
but yeah I think for me I started out
like kind of okay and then I and then
there was a period of time where as
raining a lot and I was like oh this
just feels like the whole world is
depressing and sad and then after that
week then the Sun came out yeah yeah it
was raining so much rain and I was like
oh my god this just feels like the
world's ending but then after that the
Sun came out it's been really great
weather and I've just been taking my
dogs for walks and trying to exercise
and stuff but for me I think I found
this quarantine to be both good and bad
I think like everyone but I have a goal
which is to study for the CPA exam so
I'm just kind of pretending like
nothing's really happening and I'm just
like a college kid again and I'm just
cramming for a test and like I have a
goal I have something to work
so that's made it a little bit better
versus when it kind of first started I
was like well what am I gonna like I'm
just wasting time like I'm gonna lose
money like I'm like I just felt like
everything was falling slipping out of
my hands but now I'm like huh
I mean literally no one can do anything
so it's fine I mean you just got to do
what she could do so that's kind of
where I'm at I'm I think I'm mentally
doing okay with it now it's a treat
because like as much as I am an
introvert I don't like this because it's
not like I necessarily want to go out
it's that I want the options told to do
that's a I don't know what to do but I
do like that and I don't like how
everything happened like I don't like
what brought us into these circumstances
but I will say that I used to feel
really guilty if I ever put some of my
own projects ahead of other people so I
gotten so in the habit of like when Bose
was talking about the hustle and bustle
of LA it's really great together the
depression because you're constantly
working but I also felt like like I was
giving all of my time and energy to
everybody else and when I came to work
time to work on my stuff I didn't have
any left
and so now I'm finally like getting the
spark back from my own projects and it's
been that's what's been really feeling
nice and I don't have to have the guilt
of you know saying no to a different
project or like people being like whoa
why can't you hang with us on Saturday
no birthday no phones nothing to do yeah
so yeah I think that's partly for me why
I've been happy it's also been a really
good introspective time like a time to
you know for self-improvement and
looking within and I feel like I've
gotten to like heal a lot of past
relationships and just things that I had
been putting off that like you don't
realize weigh you down day to day but
they are in there still because he kind
of like pushed him to the side and brush
them off and brush them off I feel like
it really this quarantine has really
helped to like bring all those things to
the surface and like let them out so I
feel really like cleansing sort of
feeling through this time which is I
kind of know that not everyone's
experienced but yeah I think that's cool
though to Nikki because it's like you
get to finally like learn how to like
really really take care of yourself and
you feel how good it
feels and you don't feel all this
pressure from LA because in LA like
especially in our world we feel like not
that we have to compete but we feel like
we have to catch up or keep up with
people and so I feel like this is
something that once it's all over you'll
be able to take with you and I think all
of us should be looking for a lesson or
a skill to take with us out of this you
know just to ease the pain a little bit
pressure this article recently where
they were talking about how with every
generation there's like something
impactful that changes the way we live
in the world so for example like with us
when we were kids 9/11 happened and then
that's how like TSA come about and all
this stuff so they were just analyzing
like how is the world gonna change after
this cuz this entire experience has
taught us like a lot of stuff can't get
it done from home but it's also taught
us that it's important to have social
interaction before mental health too so
I don't know I get I start thinking
about that cuz like I've been getting
deliveries for like furniture pieces and
stuff and people were just like no we
can't go inside your house like like you
like how they used to in the past and so
that has been a change like a small
change but it is still a change so I
wonder if that's gonna remain in the
future and like other things too like
our day-to-day lives like how
everything's gonna change like art
people are gonna be judgemental every
time someone sneezes or like I remember
like it was like when we would go flying
and like in the airports and the
airplanes and certain people will get to
strip discriminated based off of the
events that happened so I don't know I
hope one derp what can happen she says
my allergies just allergies please stop
I honestly like I've been watching a lot
of stuff with like historical pandemics
and like history things that have
happened before and it's like there's
been even a Philip DeFranco video I
think he put out recently he like went
through a list of some recent in the
last hundred years like pandemics and
outbreaks Gina no chances Nikki I kinda
feel like
doesn't stop it I'm getting it Gina it's
you from spreading it yeah I couldn't
ask woman I don't think that things are
gonna change
honestly after this that much because
it's like well it's really not like it
never did before
pandemic never really changed anything
before just made scientists more
interested in the field and it just
means our government's gonna spend a lot
more money on catching pandemics but
like daily life things like once the
virus is gone or we all have a the shot
or whatever it's like how like why would
it still affect beyond that you know I
think psychologically though there'll be
changes because like I said like like if
like more people are gonna be constantly
washing their hands which is a good
thing but like there's certain little
like changes in your mind like the way
you see things like the way you interact
with the world like people that have
experienced all of this I feel like for
sure you're gonna walk out of this
changed internally somehow what's been
so weird dude it's just like I kind of
have like a weird day the other day cuz
I went out to like because of essentials
and ever into the bank and like
everything say hey we're letting two
people in or do this whatever and just
yeah you know like everyone's wearing
gloves and masks and I'm like and I
thought about like jubileus it's like
this for I don't know if like a while it
is kind of depressing you know I miss
just going out and having a reason to
get dressed up and just go out I kind of
miss doing errands you know what I mean
yeah or like the freeways are so empty
the streets are totally quiet at night
when I hear cops drive by oh my god oh
my god this is like it's like a weird
time in life right now maybe it would
help people appreciate what we had
before you know like I feel like a lot
of people are sharing a sentiment of
like dang I shouldn't have taken those
things for granted like I didn't know
what I had yeah that for sure cuz that's
like 12 or 18 months of us having to do
like pretty heavy social distancing
which I feel like is kind of the maximum
even a lot of people are saying that I
mean it's it's things are gonna go back
to normal we might we're just gonna be
more aware of like you know how a
disease spreads and how we should be
more clean and things like that but I
honestly don't feel like it's gonna be
like this forever you know cuz it wasn't
after the the Spanish flu like it you
know people weren't wearing masks
doesn't know and all that stuff for the
last hundred years it's just like it
happens for a little while it's
encapsulated within like a two-year
period and then we move on and we
prepare for the next one I don't think
it's you know zero that you know like
another example from our article I was
reading was certain people that were
children during the Great Depression and
throughout their lives like they would
constantly hoard food because they just
never knew when it was gonna happen
again so that's true change role I'm
talking about I've been told y'all I've
been doomsday prepping since summer of
last year and when this [ __ ] hit like
did I tell you about this i watch tell
people because they're gonna go rob you
you they know now to go rob two cans of
peas and i'm gonna steal all of them
that's right thank you
Thank You Tiffany I was watching it one
day I may have been a little blitz and I
was watching it and I was like look
they're trying to make these people look
crazy but they're on to something I'll
tell you that right now
you know I started thinking about them
I'm like what are they all saying every
grocery store I would just buy two extra
cans it's right there in the kitchen I
got it I ain't playing you think of all
these conspiracy theories though coming
out cuz like oh like the government did
okay so guys a while ago Nikki told me
this conspiracy theory that the kovat
was actually in the u.s. around December
or like November or so and in December I
have it was I'd know exactly the exact
date cuz I went back and looked it was a
SEP the week of December 16th I had the
worst sickness I had ever had in my
entire life I was out of work for eight
days in business days I mean through the
weekends through the whole week and my
other friend that had the same illness
so they said that I had bronchitis
my and also I had a flu shot the month
before this so I was like I was so mad
that I'd gotten sick my company provided
flu shots so I I get this really bad
illness it turns into bronchitis and my
coworker that also had it first
so bad that it turned into pneumonia and
she had to get an inhaler and then she
had to get another inhaler when the
first one ran out and she had never had
any history of asthma however had to get
an inhaler so like after Nikki told me
that that they thought it was in the US
in December which she told me this like
a month ago and there's actually been
more articles that have come in I talked
to her and I was like dude what were
your symptoms when she had that she was
like dude I couldn't stop coughing and I
couldn't breathe and I was like bro I
truly genuinely believe that we may have
had it in December yeah for sure I
believe that even maybe even November I
feel like this definitely spread way
before that that is the only conspiracy
thing that I do believe is that it was
here like October November December for
sure first yeah it is fast before my
life I didn't get it but whatever get it
yeah I know like when I was [ __ ] the
ones i my auntie was like I don't think
it was I don't think so Gina right
because I got I got sick up so I've
actually been sick twice in the past
three months
I guess my I don't know what's going on
but I guess it also could just be
different strands but the after I got
sick when I saw you Gina it just felt
like a cold it felt like a head cold but
this one in December it was it was
really bad when I would come into the
office like if I like mic off was so bad
that it sounded like a [ __ ] deity
like it was like eight people at once
it was so bad like I and then the third
day I tried to come back into work after
I was on antibiotics and I coughed once
and they were like you need to leave
yeah and like that's all I know the
exact date because my boss texted me
that yeah it was really bad oh yes oh
yes miss the most cuz right now like I
really miss nail salons me do I need a
pedicure like nothing else get a mani
pedi together yeah my nails are poppin
but my
I got your own nails no no no I haven't
done that in years
I you are you hard gels though and they
last for up to six weeks and so I had
just gotten them done like two days
before the lockdown so that was pretty
lucky but my pedicure is peeling off and
I lack
and then I filed them down to cuz he's
like yeah do you guys remember how you
always had a long yeah yeah those are my
natural nails and your after taking off
that hard gel
there were like paper-thin so I may have
bending you need this great you need a
host break enough yeah that's true
yeah and I miss Korean barbecue oh yeah
restaurants for me because I'm single
restaurants and bars where I can be like
you know out and about and getting laid
or during some call be right after we
get off this car you're the other
married one here how's your sex life
been since the quarantine good now that
we're talking about doing whatever your
answer first
well okay so we had like a dry spell for
a minute and then kick back up but we
are not trying to get pregnant anymore
yes during this time I'm like I do not
want to be in a hospital like it's scary
scary time yeah actually right tomorrow
is my beginning of the fertile week so
we're like no no now we're being careful
but it's been awesome I mean it like
some days we get on each other's nerves
where we get we have like cabin fever
where we're just like ah but then like I
don't know like a few hours later then
we kind of get over here we're like well
there's no one else here thank you
we have to just kind of get along and
love like leading on to the night and
then you know it's it's cute it kind of
like forced you into romance yeah
honestly yeah how about you well Steve
and Aloha we've had less sex than ever
Oh
that's not like we're still like hanging
out we still have fun yet we're best
friends like I love like we're we love
hanging out with each other genuinely
and that's what I love the most about a
relationship but usually we have a date
night and when Gina was talking about
going out for restaurants like usually
date night is when you get dressed up
you go out to a restaurant you spend one
in one-on-one time without the phone
without a TV we're we're just connecting
and we realized even though we were
still doing date nights they were like
binge watching Tiger king or you know
like watching Ozark and it wasn't
leading to sex because we weren't
actually connecting like we weren't like
having the time where we're like you
know talking to each other so like we
were laughing about the show but like we
weren't like connecting and so yeah like
it would be weird because and because
everything's so the time has been so off
were like you people are going to bed at
weird times and waking up over your
times I want it when he doesn't want it
and then he wants it when I don't want
it and like it's just been
we've just been missing each other and I
think it's just cuz there hasn't been
like as much of her routine I've seen on
my same routine but Steve's an extrovert
he really misses talking to people and I
guess the only time extroverts like to
talk to people are till like 2:00 in the
morning
so because bed late he's been live
streaming with Joe chats Okawa and yeah
oh my god I have to tell you something
that guy okay can I say this is affected
my early because I I miss my guy more
than ever I feel like I took every day
that we spent together for granted like
it feels like us spending time together
is so so far away in the past month
we've seen each other once last so we've
been trying to FaceTime a lot more and
just stay connected last night i
facetimed him after I finished my stream
and when I answered he looked at me he
said whoa and I'm like what and he was
like wow I feel like when we started
dating
you were like hot and he was like but
now you're like beautiful Oh
Oh ready hit man no and that's that's
what it was I feel like I looked like
[ __ ] I just had these glasses on and I'm
like and I just I don't know like he's
he said like he was like yeah you're
gorgeous and I was just like Oh heart
because like it made me feel like
something like when a guy first starts
dating you they're like oh yeah my
girlfriend's [ __ ] hot she's sexy and
then it's like when they start to like
really respect you and she was like
wifey status they're like my girl is
beautiful and when he said that's me it
felt like so like genuine and like he
couldn't help but say it and it just I
miss him so so - oh my I'm doing that
thing beause you know I think in the
maybe it's the last episode that came
out the one about being happy being
single that thing where you said oh just
take a period of time and not be like
kind of dating anyone or like crushing
on anyone or anything like that like I
feel like that was kind of forced upon
me so but actually I think it's good I
been really feeling good like not having
anyone that I'm thinking about or like
oh stressing over or are we gonna date
are we not like I just kind of dropped
all the side dudes that I kind of had
going on
like I'm glad you know I'm killing it
offended with the weird guy before yeah
my favorite but there was a different
there was another one that I don't know
he was just just wait can we talk about
that talk about yeah
so I felt like he was kind of weird
because he was just like when I we would
so we would we saw each other only three
times like four actual dates before the
quarantine had us shut down and then but
then like if we would text or talk about
sex or anything he would get super weird
and like he was saying like he wanted to
wait like three months and I would be
like holy [ __ ] and he you know I guess
that's I don't know to me that's a lot
I'm sorry it's a lot to most people it's
not but to me it's a lot and then when I
would be like whoa that's a lot then you
would be like that's a lot really maybe
I should make you wait six months or
like he would make little jokes and
stuff and I would be like honey I'm not
gonna make it like I'm not gonna make
you know like so not even just about sex
it's also about like as women we're like
you mean we can go on three dates and
you don't want to have sex with me at
all like do you even like me it's a
little bit of her saying I want him to
respect me in two way to not be just out
for sex but then the fact that he was
like oh we're just don't do that I don't
I wait like three months or six months
and I'm like we're just not a good match
I guess okay I can't wait that long yeah
yeah do you guys think it was small dick
like a probably yeah like mother like
you like he was cool he was so tall he
was like six four his hands were huge
what small dicks oh yeah I did it at all
dude with a small dick mm-hmm well small
been like where he was just maybe he
could have just been really emotional I
don't know maybe he got hurt or
something but yeah I don't I can't deal
with that baggage so I don't know also I
can't deal with crooked teeth
does anyone else deal with crooked ass
teeth because I don't anymore same yeah
so I you know you guys we have been
spending a ton of time at home so now is
the best time to try candid Co so it's
these candid are clear aligners that are
comfortable removable it's wholly
visible oh wait David something wrong I
got stuck here anyway
back to the campus so candid or clear
aligners are comfortable removable and
they're totally invisible so you can
transform your smile without anyone
noticing a thing and like I said the
fact that we're all at home now is the
perfect time because candid ends up
mailing you your aligners and you are
connected to an experienced orthodontist
and so that includes remote monitoring
by that same word Adonis so you'll never
have to wonder how everything's going
you're constantly interacting and making
sure that you have a good plan
and so like I said this orthodontist
keeps an eye on your treatment from
anywhere so if you're planning ahead for
a special event with candid the avid
average treatment length is just six
months so you'll start seeing results
way before then you would imagine coming
out of quarantine with perfectly
straight teeth
uglier during some reason yeah it's so
funny true so are you ready to take that
first step toward straighter teeth or a
limited you can get started yes both get
started with the $75 off by using code
mood at candid co.com slash mood that's
candid co.com slash mood use code mood
for $75 off candid co.com slash mood
code thankfully these a lot of these
mailing companies like they can survive
through this [ __ ] like man good for them
and thank you for continuing to be our
sponsor and supporting us to this time
yeah yeah and also like okay i don't
want to be corny but thanks everyone
else just for watching because we are so
blessed to like be able to still do this
and be able to shoot remotely and do
what we do and it's literally all
because of everyone that's like watching
us and just hanging out with us during
quarantine we got to do a livestream
soon oh yeah that would be fun dude
business has been rough lately my dad
had to shut down his nail salon for a
month no no no Casey's parents with the
with the restaurant they've had to shut
down completely
Wow so bad for all the small businesses
oh yeah I don't know right now yeah I
I'm like there's I'm really happy to see
so many creators in particular like
creators and celebrities raising money
whether it be for like Kovan relief like
economy relief or whether it be like
putting into research to it I'm just
really happy to see so many people step
up and do their part in some way they
can like I mean like me like I'll have a
lot of money I can't be donating like
you know 80 grams you know you know that
kind of money right but am I gonna like
hit my post mate you know 25 30 % like
apps yeah I'm fighting from small
businesses to and yeah anybody that I
know personally that's been like laid
off or like affected by it I've been
likes to sending them grocery gift cards
and stuff like that yes just so that
they like you know like basic needs
should be taken care of that's exactly
like small common pop Chinese
restaurants cuz they've been getting hit
real hard dude yeah especially because a
lot of people are like oh they're Asian
so they pay have the virus so I don't
want to order for me more so she's like
low intelligence like that so I ordered
I ordered from like a mom-and-pop
Chinese restaurant the other day and I
put this on my fridge they actually sent
me on a little thing I think it's
backwards but it says thank you for
supporting for thank you for your
support during these hard times
so whenever I've been ordering like no
matter what I want to eat I try to order
from something like home just a hometown
kind of shop yeah yeah from moment
popped I rest Iran Slyke no others our
favorite Thai restaurant is this mom and
pop down straightener it's so good they
like know us by name now because if I
ordered food and I got a load note like
that my food would taste like tears
while I'm eating it dude no I feel bad I
haven't been ordering in at all like I
went to the grocery store like on Friday
the 13th when when the everyone I think
it was the state of emergency was
announced then I just bought a bunch of
[ __ ] I've just been eating food at home
I haven't should I be ordering out more
that's you yeah I am yeah good for me
I've also so I we were trying to order
food before they complete shutdown and
it was goodbye this like emergency taco
kit thing from this one restaurant and
it was with us for like a like a week
and a hat like I don't know that's
that's a long time we think that is are
you talking about it was it good okay
tomboys oh so it's it's like two big-ass
containers or like chicken and beef and
then 30s and then salsas angry rice and
then a cart
bags like 30 eggs Wow and it was
supposed to come with four toilet paper
rolls - but there was only one which is
I don't care we didn't need to lever but
so I had heard that this restaurant was
really really really good and we had
been wanting to try it so that's the
reason why we ordered it and we also
wanted to support itself but I don't
blame them cuz they were just cooking a
lot but it wasn't that great when I read
fetus parent
there probably weren't even thinking
about like I mean how do you really make
those are just massive massive plates of
food it's like yeah it was like the
container things like rupturing so it
was like the pieces were cut really big
and it's like I'm Nessa so you need like
smaller pieces are really tough so that
was your tensioning and I like that it
was kind of dry that Thea's were really
really like not good the rice was
including a soggy so it's a boy but
honestly was but I wasn't trippin hard
cuz I'm like it's feeding us it's and
then Casey ended up chopping up the meat
it's smaller so and then he he made it
work so makes the case you can make
anything work I feel yeah he's talented
in the kitchen so we were all to eat
okay lightening the idea or the name of
an emergency taco kit though yeah
properly that I would probably be
ordering that every Monday or every
Sunday and just eating that throughout
the week would you like a whole last
month by yourself like one
when Casey's family was here there was
nine of us at one point and it fed us
all like and there was still [ __ ] so no
food left
damn yeah I'm so so jelly that you guys
like I get to like with your husband
mine is driving me crazy
drive me crazy but I wonder do you guys
actually kind of keep distance cuz I
know your office is upstairs Mickey and
his downstairs like guys get to stay
apart the whole day and then come
together at night like huh I mean I was
happy ceccolini has changed because
that's live livings and we really serve
you the reason we got this place was so
that we could each work during the day
cuz we both work from home and we worked
on a lot of projects together and
obviously we live together we're married
together so like in order to not
get overwhelmed with how much time we
spend together we work during the days
in our office but I think because of the
quarantine and because like what Gina
was talking about like being told to
stay home even though we would normally
be working at home Steve is like I gotta
get out of here like we got it
I gotta go talk to people I give me any
go to the store don't even tell them to
stay his ass home yeah yeah now we're
not even supposed to go to the grocery
store for like seven days straight like
the city wants people don't go to the
grocery store my mind groceries so
that's good you've ordered twice already
so like that we're good yeah but yeah
like kill bug me throughout the day cuz
he just wants someone to talk to I let
him bug me because it's cute it it it's
like he needs it more than I do I wonder
like how many how many I want to know
after all this I want to know the
divorce rates and the baby birthing
rates baby
I lived into the baby birth well I
didn't look at you maybe like this
evening yeah yeah Casey's mom sent me
this article where they were talking
about how like in the past like history
shows that when there's a lot of people
dying the birth rate goes down but
afterwards when everything goes back to
normal that's when it shoots back up so
I don't think there's gonna be a baby on
it really happening but especially being
scared like to go into hospitals and
like just in case you get pregnant like
I'm not trying to get pregnant out so I
think a lot of people are probably on
the same tip so I don't think it's gonna
be a boom I think it's so funny because
guess who guess who the two people have
gotten to check taco was advocating for
tick tock wouldn't this happen was I not
talking about six hahaha
I'm the one that said I will never be on
tick-tock and they never get me yeah I
was against it I got some viral and
she's like hey Stan you or I didn't
understand I thought it was musically
and I had check out musically a couple
years ago when musically was popping off
and it was like a bunch of kids
lip-synching and I'm like I'm not into
this at all yeah so wouldn't it talk
bought it I just thought it was still
that and then I started scrolling after
playlists were a bunch of people oh gee
youtubers were like yo you need to check
out tick tock it's like how YouTube was
in the beginning I'm like really and so
I started scrolling and I was like oh oh
I get it it's like a bunch of inside
jokes that you get to be part of and I
like as I started like understanding the
tone more I was like okay I'll try one
or two and I did not expect because
their algorithm does not play favorites
it does not matter all the way my [ __ ]
before because I didn't have him any
following it all on tick tock I didn't
even promote my tick tock at all and it
ended up one of my tick tocks the the
fifth or sixth one I did was just a
random cooking one that I was just like
making banana bread and I wasn't even
thinking it was gonna be a crazy it was
pretty funny though Nikki it was pretty
you're so good at stirring yeah she was
like yeah I was like it's Nikki
drunkenness because you're like gonna
get a couple of nasty boy honestly this
is like my tasty Tuesday videos in a
1-minute video format and yeah it ended
up on people's 4u page and even people
that are Emma that's like the trending
page or the popular whatever like the
explore page and so like even people
that I knew in real life we're having my
video pop up and that to me tells me
that it really doesn't matter who you
are you can start you can do a tick-tock
and you can have your tick-tock end up
on the explore page unlike YouTube I I
love it though I yeah a guy that I
worked with like a few months ago I saw
his tick tock pop-up on the page I was
like what and it had like a minute like
8 million views and and like Nikki I
think I saw yours got to like one like
what a million views or something like
that it's like one point
right now like in because every day a
the first day it had 10,000 I know how
YouTube it's like whatever the first
days views are that's probably like the
peak so the first day I was like 10,000
I was like okay cool like that was the
first time I went five digits in the in
the views and and then all of a sudden
my notifications kept popping off
throughout the week and it's like three
days later it was at like 500,000 views
and then like days after that it was at
like a million and I was like whoa this
is wild like it just keeps pushing it
out so their discovery it was
epinephrine I think the other thing
about it though is Niki is that like
you've been doing YouTube and like you
know sketch stuff and timing like that
is really like an expertise of yours and
when I watch the video your your points
like it just flowed really well so
anyone that has like knowledge of video
editing or that is good at it like tick
tock is such an amazing tool for them
because I I even get addicted until I
actually filmed it and I saw how the
interface worked
yeah you can't rearrange and I think
it's you know the really crazy thing is
all the gen Z kids
dude it's if their abilities are amazing
like people are now making thumbnails
most people make their thumbnails for
YouTube on their phone through a photo
editing app and you can edit everything
through the app itself you don't need to
open up premiere you don't need to do
that and the fact that like now the
device it's not this whole computer it's
this little phone and these kids can do
everything that we could do 10 years ago
I think that's really amazing and I'm
just kind of stoked to really just be a
part of that culture and see where it
goes and see the creativity of people my
age and those younger than me I think
it's really dope I like oh my god by the
way well dance you talk big bus but
you're so funny
there's so funny I would go to bed at
like 1:00 a.m. and next I'm watching
tick tock miles on the Sun's up like
yeah that's all control man dude because
you know like you and you what I said
that Gina wakes up when the start of Sun
is starting to go down so it is exactly
where things you I said because of that
reason because I know
that I could easily get addicted to it I
the app as much yeah and I only see tick
tucks whenever they pop up on my Twitter
cuz I have an account now but I cannot
open the app cuz then I'm gonna lose
like no hire week of my life I can't do
it it's also like I see it as a business
sense to like if you're in entertainment
already you should just make it takes up
just to have it you know cuz it could be
another stream of income for you for
sure man look at these these like like
actually ice I opened up the tick tock
act app and then I accidentally created
it takes off which I've never posted of
Casey or something and then I was
editing in I'm just like whoa there's so
many options that I got overwhelmed
where I'm like I can't deal with this
and I just like I closed it I'm like I
don't know how yeah I'll see it when it
pops up on my Twitter feed but I don't
know if I can actually get involved
myself because I get too overwhelmed
with the amount of options like I don't
know what yeah
yeah yeah I love it
I'm trying to make more but then that
requires putting on the makeup in
additions you know what I've been doing
like another so during quarantine like
it's hard to work so I've been focusing
on my digital stuff like whether it be
you know twitch streaming doing stuff
with you guys and if I put makeup on for
the day I try I've been trying to shoot
you tick-tock afterwards so like over
the past week I've done like three so I
have another one that I'm gonna do but
I've just been doing little story times
about really bad dates and stuff so it's
been easy like it's hard for me to think
of like sketches and funny stuff I get
nervous and I'm like is this good enough
so I'd rather just like tell stories but
it's it feels really cool because it
seems like people like it and you just
finally it's like a platform I can be
ugly on and nobody's like I just have to
fix my eyebrows and put some glasses on
and they're like wow bro I think that's
what I like about it too is that like
you can express yourself in what way
feels comfortable for you because when I
was thinking of trying to make like
sketches with it it was kind of daunting
cuz it's like oh no I have to be funny
and like a short amount of time but then
when I was just like [ __ ] around
making banana bread like I like I
already make stuff on my YouTube channel
like that and I was just you know you
know cooking and I don't have to show my
face I was I didn't show my face the
whole video I only showed you space so I
didn't have makeup on and I know I kind
of
like oh I found my format I don't have
to pay for it you know what you know
it's funny Nikki I I noticed that I
noticed that a lot of people are really
popular on tik-tok for just like doing
their day to day like it's almost like
Instagram stories but take talk and
there's some people that do that it's
like their own little diary and our
friend Jess here does some great little
stories like that
I could totally see Jess blowing up on
tick-tock just from posting stories of
her day to day in quarantine probably do
it no I can't
I'm leaving social media so I'm not on
the social media platform like I barely
post on Instagram I deleted my youtube
channel I'm like on the way out so y'all
aren't gonna get me back in I'm sorry
you're so good on Twitter to you right
now yeah the title of this video is just
as quitting yeah great clickbait we
should do that just quit bows made just
quit let's call it that oh yeah it's
juicy that's so mean quit me they won't
believe that a little more crazy yeah I
know that's true so you'll never do
tick-tock Jess cuz I said that then look
at them now they never definitely never
I might put it on record that I will
never be on tick-tock yeah alright cut
that okay that into a tick-tock I'm
gonna cut it you can use me if you want
to use found footage of me you can
create take talks for me yeah we'll do
that but we'll reconvene on this next
week I'll see if Jess yeah yeah I need
to go take my sick snap of the day bye I
got a pee
guys we should do themes for our next
one we should have like yeah I want to
do formal formal for them we'll
brainstorm maybe I need to get an updo
done but there's no one to do my hair
for me so if we do formal oh my god
that's cute hairstyles good tik-tok look
like a glass of wine yeah wine glasses
I wanna get a red cup of wine I don't
care like you know cause he has whole
bottle Jess there you go oh yeah
can you imagine me like lifting esashi
chugging tequila
all right everybody well thank you for
watching I hope this was interesting for
you hope you're related I mean honestly
everyone's just kind of winging it we're
all in the same position all over the
world and I think that's kind of
interesting in a way that we're all in
the same position yeah and I hope you're
handling the quarantine well and make
sure to subscribe so you can hang out
with us during it cuz we'll be here
waiting D Niki yes yes do you know I can
see your butt oh my god get out of here
[Music]
[Applause]